let's talk about come to Daddy yes tell
us about it this is I mean I know about
it but I want I want our audience to
know about come to - it's a cool it's
it's a cool story come to Daddy
is a Chandra comedy sort of thriller II
film takes a lot of twists and turns but
essentially the film is about a guy who
is a sort of musician DJ kind of douchey
guy who has been estranged from his
father for 30 years and it's about him
revisiting his father for the first time
since he was five and reuniting and it's
about what happens between these two
people and and the sort of course of
events that takes place in this small
sort of you know Pacific Northwest town
and what I like about one of the things
that I think is neat is you keep finding
out more and more things yes about
you're just going back to see your dad
yes you are estranged but you keep
finding more and more things out about
your dad's life that you were not
prepared absolutely to understand yes
and it goes some pretty twisted places
ok we have a clip here from come to
Daddy I think this is when your you guys
are so estranged your dad doesn't really
even know much about what you do he
knows nothing about me and I'm trying to
impress him with my my career Who I am
what I'm what I've accomplished and it
ends up sounding pretty ridiculous and
my father doesn't give a [ __ ] let's take
a look at this clip from come to Daddy
I'm in the music business ok I'm fairly
big in the music business but you are
what I am a singer or something
I'm not someone you can pigeonhole if
I'm completely honest do i DJ yes do I
produce blazing beats yes do I
tickle the ivories yes do I promote
high-profile events pertaining to music
and the performance of music yes okay
the combination of the hit for this role
the combination of the haircut you had
and the mustache I think we may have a
still I don't know if we have a still of
it but yeah yeah that is that is such a
great character choice you know it's a
lot of fun new monk I don't know what
that's called we had a lot of but it's
always fun as an actor to get to
disappear into something yeah and this
character was so specific and and there
were actually ideas for the way that he
was gonna look that we're crazier but
it's just fun to do that kind of thing
and I have that kept the mustache for
like a month after right the problem is
when you're doing a movie like that as
is often this comes with the acting gig
yeah you're walking around in your
regular life with that hair and that
mustache say what were weekend's yeah
yeah Wow Elijah Wood is a douche yeah I
tried to make it as presentable as I
possibly could come to daddy is in
theaters and available on digital and
video on demand right now and people
love it Elijah Wood always great